soulagement donc pour ces touristes
québécois coincé en haïti en raison des
manifestations qui déchire le pays
ils ont finalement pu être évacués par
hélicoptère vers l'aéroport de port au
prince et seront de retour au pays ce
soir on retrouve là bas notre envoyé
spécial philippe leuba alors filez
peuvent vous les avez rencontré en fait
à leur arrivée à l'aéroport il était
somme toute satisfait de l'opération
pour l'opération qui a commencé vers 9h
ce matin quatre appareils avaient été
nolisés pour héliporter par petits
groupes les 113 passagers
les passagers dont qui sont arrivés à
l'aéroport de port au prince
accueillis par du personnel consulaire
et sont ensuite montés à bord d'un
airbus 321 le vol transat 6 7 en
direction de montréal en ce moment qui
va arriver vers 20h50 à l'aéroport
trudeau
donc j'ai rencontré ces touristes
québécois je leur ai demandé quels
étaient leurs premières impressions
après
encore de port au prince avaient l'air
très organisée et puis on fait ça très
rapidement puis c'est vraiment piloter
aujourd'hui on est content de tard vers
l'aéroport où il y avait des gens qui
qui se plaignait son vous qui voulait
partir mais après c'est ces mêmes gens
se payer parce qu'il s'en allait dans la
neige donc été au final c'est ça il y en
a toujours des points comptant tout est
parfait on peut pas demander mieux
ces gens sont près de l'endroit mais on
ne peut plus rien vu et n'ont même pas
pu chausser d'hôtel et pendant ce temps
télé plus un calme relatif est revenu
dans les rues de port au prince
pour les gens qui étaient terrés chez
eux depuis neuf jours en 32 violence en
a profité pour sortir aujourd'hui
essayer d'aller visiter les stations
d'essence les banques qui étaient
ouvertes pour la première fois en
plusieurs jours
certaines personnes sont demeurées à la
maison encore créative sur le cadeau
berne guerre que j'ai rencontrés lui il
est revenu en haïti et l'autre l'été
passé il avait passé un an à montréal
était arrivé sur le chemin rock sam avec
tous ces migrants qui finalement avait
été renvoyé en a ici donc je vais
demander dans quelles conditions ils
vivaient ici nous a montré une bouteille
d'eau qui est évident c'est que trois
jours je sais trouver de l'eau potable
je n'en trouve pas je n'ai pas de
travail jeudi à l'électricité à peine
six heures par jour je ne sais pas
combien de temps je pourrai encore
envoyé ma fille à l'école parce que je
n'ai pas les moyens de le payer donc on
peut écouter ce qu'ils avaient à nous
dire aujourd'hui si dans un pays low
européen luxe ça c'est ce n'est pas un
même lot qui est plus que la terre
devait luxe il n'y a pas de vie mais
haïti n'est pas une vie les gens qui
vivent en haïti ci ne sais pas mais pour
moi c'est cesser de la faire
prochain événement surveillée at laudine
le premier ministre va s'adresser à la
nation à 20h ce soir et des
manifestations sont prévues demain entre
autres en direction de la résidence du
président joël maurice donc plusieurs
haïtiens des millions des syriens
continuent de réclamer la démission
merci beaucoup peiné ponsard prend plus